on a décidé plus tôt cette semaine de
s'intéresser à la santé des autochtones
à la veille de la journée nationale ou
internationale du sida mondiale
elle touche tout le monde pour nous en
parler je vous présente nos invités
gilbert emont vous êtes professeur à
l'université concordia montréal bonjour
bonjour et vous êtes accompagné de
sylvain beaudry
alors vous êtes coordonnateur navigateur
autochtone chez médecins du monde
bonjour jours bien sûr charlebois
correctionnelle à cette semaine nous
allons nous intéresser charles un
événement qui se déroule pendant le
marché de noël de wend à quai et ça a
lieu à ce moment-là bon parce que on
rejoint tous les wendat qui seront
présents à ce moment là on va parler
d'eux on va parler deux langues
cette semaine de la langue la langue
wendat qui n'est pas une langue morte
mais qui est une langue qui souffre je
souffre et puis mathis arvela cette
semaine un jour matisse alors avec vous
mathis on va rejoindre le sujet
principal d'aujourd'hui l'état de santé
des autochtones et donc des inuit
particulièrement en situation
d'itinérance dans le nord du canada vue
car garçon l'a fait qu'on aurait plutôt
la dimension nordique
oui absolument alors je me tourne vers
mes invités vous avez écrit une lettre
ouverte qui a entre autres été publiés
sur espace autochtone ce qui arrive
c'est que vous vous inquiétez de la
grande vulnérabilité des itinérants
autochtone à montréal alors qu'on
approche de cette journée importante et
on sait qu'ils sont particulièrement
concernés c'était le bon moment pour
parler pour sensibiliser sur les
problématiques sont du plus forte chez
les autochtones de montréal nord nos
femmes qu'être recherche exploratoire
auprès des gens qui étaient plus simples
et qualité on a dit précarité parce que
ces pansements des gens qui sont sans
abri mais qui peuvent avoir l'avoir été
qui ont des aussi souvent
comment devrions pas notamment logements
très fixe donc ça peut être pas là
certains trains peuvent être très bien
oui mais ils continuent à utiliser les
services de chaque terre de refuge aux
us en 2006 à vauvert d'accord d'accord
alors en fait dans cette lettre ouverte
où vous parlez de votre étude qu'est ce
que vous vouliez faire exactement qui
voulez vous retenir à qui voulez vous
attirer l'attention
je pense que ça se fait avec les
autochtones et pas sur les autochtones
donc c'est important de parler à tout le
monde en même temps c'est pour ça qu'on
a envoyé cette lettre là pour que
l'ensemble des communautés dont la
communauté dont les communautés
autochtones en particulier soit plus
sensibilisés à la situation et puissent
agir plus aussi plans d'armes aigles
leur situation face à ce qui se passe
c'est notre début d'intervention pour
sensibiliser dire mais en attendant la
trouver des solutions et on veut pas
attendre que le gouvernement décide pour
le dire aux autochtones par exemple
d'accord et ses solutions là vous les
avez trouvés à travers cette enquête que
vous avez appelé rencontre on la pierre
en compte les rencontres un canter story
c'était parce qu'on voulait rencontrer
parce qu'on voulait faire les choses
avec eux et c'est dans ce sens là qu'on
le fait qu'on a trouvé des problèmes des
problématiques en opposition à trouver
des solutions pour l'instant c'est ça
qu'on aime qu'on sait on s'attelle voilà
directement et vous avez travaillé entre
autres avec monsieur beaudry mais vous
n'êtes pas que tous les deux sur cette
grande enquête non n'était que ce que
des chercheurs ou dans des autochtones
et des gens qui qui qui venait du réseau
de du vih et d'autres d'autres le milieu
d'accord alors qu'y avez-vous approché
au coeur de cette enquête là on est allé
avec le sel c'est métro on avait des
infirmières qui était qui était
spécialisé des jeux dans le dépistage et
qui connaissait quitté key faire
clientèle itinérante du vih autochtone
oui alors sont annie dans l'ide en me
refusant ainsi altéra open door chez
doris au centre d'amitié autochtone
aussi tous les organismes tous les gens
qui déjà en situation pouvait on avait
la réputation de trouver oui oui on
voulait parce qu'on n'avait pas beaucoup
de sous on a dit on va les construit ou
est-ce qu'on pourrait rencontrer le la
situation la pire encore on espère que
c'est la pire existe déjà beaucoup mais
on voudra pas que ce soit pire que ça
d'accord alors vous avez interrogé ces
personnes interviewées parce qu'on
voulait connaître leur parcours de vie
un peu et aussi la rue s'ils
connaissaient leur statut vih si ce cas
c'est aussi l'hépatite c
s'ils étaient infectées par l'hépatite c
est quand même une problématique plus
important que le vih à montréal pour les
autochtones y tient et on a aussi
regardé les mts donc on faisait un
dépistage complet leur plein soutien à
ces situations et vous avez approché
beaucoup de monde
deux cents 200 paires de seins c'est un
gros échantillons dans ce cas là quand
on est une petite population comme
peut-être 1902 autochtone qu'à montréal
deux seins c'est énorme
enfin 900 itinérante 900
peugeot oui c'est ça ce n'est peut-être
900 on sait pas exactement en situation
d'itinérance ou de pré qualifiés et donc
qu'ils peuvent avoir lu des séjours
d'avoir des amis ou pas d'ami pas de
réseau mais qui utilise les ressources
pour annie un chercher un minimum de
sauve il est alors parmi ses 200
personnes là qui sont autant des
premières nations des métis ou des inuit
un oui tout le monde est inclus tenons
tout inclus sous la plupart par des
anglais plus que français parce que
beaucoup 18 entre autres font partie de
cette clientèle oui c'est ça on en sur
la présentation et à terme de proportion
et c'est beaucoup beaucoup de nous et
tenir le lot des accents et qu'est ce
qu'ils vous ont dit déjà est ce qu'ils
se sont ouverts suffisamment pour que
vous puissiez dresser un portrait assez
juste de la situation
oui de leur état de santé pour l'état de
santé saleh s'était et elle a beaucoup
de frustration face ou pas c'est une
face à leur parcours on en arrive pas
l'os en voulant être là donc c'est un il
ya quand même une forme de décrochage
dans le parcours de vie qui fait qu'on
n'a pas réussi à avoir tout ce qu'on
voudrait bien ses proches de ce
commentaire c'est surtout en situation
de sur vivre c'est parce qu'on a on n'a
pas le choix
oui alors ça c'est clair donc ces choses
là sont à passer
yodé des parcours on n'a pas exploré
vraiment le l'immensité du parcours vous
voulez savoir c'est un contact avec leur
communauté
c'était peu en contact avec leur
déconnectez souvent il souhaiterait
avoir des contacts culturels ou sociaux
mais ça veut pas dire non plus qui
serait prête à retourner dans la
communauté et leur état de santé nuit à
quoi il ressemble en termes de dépasser
de s'effacer
c'est comme les jambes l'hépatite c est
pour le vih c'est similaire aux gens qui
sont sans abri peu importe qu'ils soient
autochtones ou pas d'accord et donc on
est dans une situation difficile parce
qu'il faut aussi pouvoir se soigner
quand on est dans une situation comme ça
si on compare à l'ouest canadien dans
les prairies en étant deux sont nés
pendant la crise comme ils sont en
saskatchewan par exemple ou quand on
nous parle de vancouver on n'est pas
dans cette situation là mais on est
similaire à ce qui se passe à toronto
donc on se retrouve que des gens qu'ils
ont à en proportion plus infectés que la
population générale
oui légèrement moins que la communauté
gay blanche l'usuel de montréal surtout
les des blancs ici et mai mais on est
dans une situation où est ce qu'il faut
faire attention
est ce que ces gens là lé la plupart
savait qu'ils étaient malades et
savaient vers quel ressources de tourner
pour obtenir de l'aide des médicaments
c'est vraiment de castille de sa victime
la plupart savait où fils et on ne peut
pas on n'est pas tombé dans une épidémie
fulgurante le c'est pas du tout ça c'est
des gens qui sont peut-être arrivé avec
le vih d'ici peut-être sont sortis de
prison avec le vih ou avec l'hépatite c
le moment de leur infection ne connaît
pas mais elle la plupart connaissaient
leur statut le connaissez maintenant
est-ce qu'ils prennent leur médication
ce qui s'ensuivit est ce qu'ils savent
ham a trouvé la ressource ça on n'est
pas sûr d'accord vous monsieur vaudry
dans le cadre de cette étude la quelle
était votre rôle
j'étais sur le comité consultatif la
recherche et j'étais aussi en lien avec
les communautés autochtones donc on a
travaillé avec l'équipe deux infirmières
qui faisons les tests pour
parler de la recherche faire connaître
la recherche aux communautés autochtones
puis ou est ce que l'on serait pour à
être tel jour tu sais faire la promotion
des heures et vous le faites en tant que
coordonnateur navigateur chi minh-ville
havas a rien à voir ça n'a rien à voir
c'était un autre jet indépendant quand
même une compétence dans le domaine du
vih depuis longtemps et impliquer de
façon complète on avait des médecins
pour donner de l'écouté mais médicaux
les infirmières pour donner le camping
ces choses là dans nos statuts sont déjà
comme sylvain pour humaniser je dirais
pour vendre la recherche accessible et
compréhensible par les gens avec qui on
parlait donc on a besoin de gens et qui
nous arrive à connecter avec lille la
culture des gens qui sont autochtones
parce que vous êtes déjà très impliquée
sur le terrain site web un g ça fait
déjà six ans que je travaille avec les
populations autochtones soit dans les
conférences où les gardes ring
les formations j'ai fait de formation
j'ai reçu des formations avec les
communautés autochtones donc ça fait à
peu près ce que je côtoie les
communautés montréal d'accord et alors
grâce à sylvain est ce que la proche
auprès des autochtones était plus facile
est ce que les gentils plus prêts à se
livrer oui c'est là qu'on voit le sens
de travailler avec les gens qui sont des
communautés ou issus des communautés
autochtones
on a besoin de leur sensibilité à qu'est
ce qu'on dit comment on dit comment ces
temps perdu là vous avez fait ce travail
là en milieu urbain est ce qu'un travail
du genre sera fait ou pourrait être fait
aussi en milieu éloigné donc dans les
communautés où en milieu rural on a
présenté les choses ou communautés
autochtones et aux gens qui étaient
autour des communautés autochtones dans
un simple 11e et le bus était justement
de dire bon c'est ça la situation qu'on
voit à montréal
est ce que vous voulez qu'on aille dans
les communautés voir comment ça se passe
peut-être que ce sera peu l'accent sur
peut-être sur le vih mais peut-être
petit c'est peut-être sur un usage des
dragons le traitement qu'on a face aux
drogues les réalités change beaucoup
selon les espaces où est-ce qu'on est à
montréal on est dans un espace
autochtone nouveau oui oui c'est vingt
mille personnes qui n'étaient pas là la
première génération général sont arrivés
leurs familles et peut-être au loin mais
ils sont ils sont en net
insertion à montréal louis
professionnelle étudiante pour vivre
tout ça la plupart ont du succès mais ça
veut dire que tu as round ou communautés
où est ce que les lézards sont beaucoup
plus proches des descentes urbain ils
peuvent pas retourner
lisez nous et peuvent pour le tourner
facilement le ciment que leur avion la
journée qu'on leur pays un avion là il
ya sept ans le matin de l'avion lors
surtout balle aussi de belles sapes à
quelqu'un je sais pas comment ça marche
mais si on peut quelqu'un qui se
retraite avait caché au oui bien sûr il
se retrouve en situation difficile loin
et de la difficulté il a des
organisations oui je m'excuse je pense
que eux savent lire les espaces plan qui
nous ont ni les espaces avec des bulles
ding ding c'est pas le même langage que
les espaces plats non en effet vous
parliez des inuits mathis la situation
vous la connaissez bien justement quand
on parle de des communautés inuit à
travers le pays principalement mais en
fait j'ai voulu ce intéressant ce sur
quoi vous êtes concentré et justement
les autochtones précisément les
autochtones en situation d'itinérance ou
de précarité parce que j'ai voulu savoir
ce qu'ils en étaient dans les
territoires du nord puis quand on
regarde les statistiques par exemple ou
du conte
la capitale à warlus on note que 82% des
itinérants qui sont autochtones mais il
faut faire attention dans
l'interprétation des données puis un
quart de la population du conte et et
autochtone
même chose du côté de l ona il faut
territoires du nord ouest il ya plus de
90% des itinérants qui sont autochtones
mais encore une fois pour une personne
sur deux est qu'il faut en prendre et en
laisser mais de manière générale au
canada dans la plupart des centres
urbains
les autochtones représentent jusqu'à la
moitié des personnes itinérantes alors
qu'ils sont à peu près ils sont près 5 %
dans la population canadienne
d'après les données là l'observatoire
canadien sur l'itinérance mais je
voudrais que dans les territoires du
nord
on est encore à l'étape de quantifier
dénombré la proportion d'itinérants tout
simplement et non pas encore à l'étape
d'identifier quels sont les les maladies
infectieuses les virus les maladies
qu'ils atteignent les autochtones en
situation d'itinérance hurricanes qu'on
n'est pas encore jusque là je sais pas
vous avez problème entendu parler de
l'opéra des opérations tout le monde
compte pointe in time comme une escale
en anglais qui ont eu lieu il y en a eu
en fait ça a eu dans une soixantaine de
villes à travers le canada
financé par le gouvernement fédéral et
quand on a regardé ce qui avait été fait
dans les territoires nordiques et le
la seule ville où il ya eu cette
opération dans les territoires du nord
c'est yellowknife territoires du nord
ouest
ça a eu lieu en 2015 et plus récemment
au printemps dernier en avril 2018
et donc c'était une sorte d'opération
peu comme vous l'avez fait un
échantillonnage donc en 24 heures des
permanents terrain qui vont essayer de
dénombrer donc à quantifier le nombre
d'autochtones d'itinérants pardon
itinérant
parce que c'est difficile avant
d'obtenir ces données là c'est fait à
montréal
à chaque achat
quelques années où c'est ça on a des
chiffres
exactement donc l unef mais comme vous
l'avez souligné c'est sûr que la notion
d'itinérance dans le nord est vraiment
différente ça fait différent et c'est
tout bête mais le climat change vraiment
la donne et brouillent un peu
l'interprétant oui il fait oui ce qui
arrive aussi dans le nord dont il ya des
villes où il ya beaucoup de mails où on
vit du surpeuplement des logements donc
l'itinérance
la priorité va se manifester
différemment dans un logement par
exemple une personne qui se retrouvent
sans logement va peut-être diriger vers
un logement surpeuplé d'une carrosserie
j'assure peu de son entourage dont il
veut poste se mettre à bondy dans la rue
par exemple mais donc il ya des réalités
qui sont différentes
exactement puis ça fait en sorte que
pour dénombrer encore une fois c'est
plus complexe et c'est ça c'est on peut
pas balisé l'itinérance en fonction des
mêmes critères que dans des villes du
sud du pont décès on distingue de
l'itinérance chronique scleck puis
situationnelle ça se restreint pas assez
cassé boire klopp est ce qu on sait
justement pourquoi est ce qu'il ya sur
représentation des autochtones dans le
milieu de l'itinérance des de ces
personnes en situation d'itinérance et
le trouver des raisons mais vous l'avez
mauvais avec wauquiez je pense que au
niveau du de l'histoire partagée par
tous bon ça revient énormément la nation
de colonialistes traumatisme
intergénérationnel génocide culturel que
la discrimination et le racisme et de
manière générale de plus en plus de
tokyo qui se dirigent vers les centres
urbains mais il ya des problématiques
qui sont vécues par les itinérants
milieu urbain qui sont spécifiques donc
aux autochtones
donc la question du surpeuplement des
logements que l'on ait dit oui dans
l'es8 nous ne gardons que se trouvent
les territoires les
les aînés du canada en 2016 40% étaient
dans 40% des inuit était habiter dans un
logement surpeuplé et noir donc la
question du surpeuplement du logement la
notion de colonialisme ou forcément
quasi un délit bld libé pardon puis le
coût élevé de la vie c'est aussi dans
l'est dans les villes nordiques ccc
c'est complètement incroyable
pour vous donner un ordre de grandeur
alouettes la capitale du nunavut le
loyer moyen par mois pour un logement de
deux chambres à coucher à oisy 2600 $ et
imaginer un majeur qui suivit du panier
d'épicerie ont été beaucoup tout et tout
et tout vient avec oui absolument
alors on parlait de surreprésentation
des autochtones des inuit chez les
personnes en situation de précarité est
inhérent ce qu'en est il de leur état de
santé justement dans les territoires et
c'est sûr que encore une fois difficile
d'identifier précisément chez les
itinérants autochtones mais au niveau du
vih c6 qui ça revient beaucoup les
autochtones sont encore ceux représentés
par dans les cas dans les bassins de
patients atteints par le vih
si on ramène ce plus localement au
nunavik dans le long du québec on l'a
déjà dit à quelques semaines et vous il
ya eu en 2010 étaient des chercheurs qui
se sont rendus sur le l'amundsen le
navire de la garde côtière canadienne ou
et accueillir des données beaucoup plus
récente que ce qui était ce qu'on avait
jusqu'à maintenant qui datait de 2004
les données sont en cours d'étude donc
si on les accroche pour les prochains
mois dire quand exactement on va les
armées mais pour dresser le portrait de
l'état santé des inuits du nord du
québec
ça va être cette étude la kings qui
veulent nous donner un meilleur portrait
de la situation et ce qu'ils ont des
services et ce qu'ils ont des portes
ouvertes où ils peuvent aller chercher
de l'aide
les médicaments ce qu'il faut pour se
soigner parce que j'imagine qu'il y en a
un certain nombre
hélas qui sont atteints du vih ou ou de
l'hépatite
il ya des insatisfaits habituel mais il
ya désormais elle sens c'est ce qu'on
retrouve souvent est ce qu'on entend
souvent c'est qu'elles sont plus limités
que dans les grands centres urbains
donc on se dira moyens souvent une
nécessité d'aller vandalisé le plus au
sud de là dedans mais je parle encore
dynamique mais lui d'aller dans les
villes plus au sud pour obtenir certains
types de traitements dont il ya toute
cette question qui revient sans cesse
comme ça sur le sud ils n'ont pas de ça
m'a l'air papier ça veut pas dire qu'ils
ont perdu peut-être que dire que
quelqu'un les a exploitées leur a enlevé
leurs papiers pour l'heure à lever leur
zèle pour limiter leur accès à des
services saas est une thématique que
souvent les infirmières nous disaient
elles n'ont pas leur cas leur carte
d'assurance maladie qui serait retenu
par parfois par un gameplay d'un travail
du sexe
on a besoin d'un squat est quelqu'un non
non non j'ai pas besoin de marquer c'est
ça dont on sait déjà qu'ils sont
appliqués aussi dans ce sens mais ils
seront pas de tonneaux millon ils
peuvent que d'avoir de 6 mai citait pas
de papiers tu peux pas aller chercher
des services la plupart des services 10
vous n'avez pas de carte d'assurance
maladie je peux pas vous aider ça veut
dire que 10 ans oui on n'a pas de sens
de son nom mais tellement qu'ils vont
aller les chercher un sommet qui a lieu
l'ingérence lundi les situations de ces
gens là mais c'est pas c'est pas comme
si on avait un service qui était ouvert
à tous c'est une forme de séquestration
oui c'en est une
sont séquestrés ici par les conditions
dans lesquelles on l'aimait si on aussi
sortent d'un d'une désintoxication et
que l'on au tibet votre avion et à
dorval à satan le matin et vous devez
être là parce que vous allez pose du
billet d'avion dans votre vie
sur le rate la viande on revient les
reins de problème assez facilement sur
le post n'est pas sale oui tu es quoi ça
nous est dangereux et donc les distances
font si vous les choses là il est
presque seule la perte de pouvoir des
uns parmi les solutions la wii dont
d'exploitation c'est de la simple
installation mais systémique et aussi
par des jacky qui je donne souvent des
ami e s qui peuplent j'imagine un état
survie décider ils font ce qu'ils
peuvent
absolument justement monsieur voterez
vous le voyez là avec médecins du monde
ont dix médecins du monde mais ses
médecins à montréal aussi parce que
l'organisme travaille sur le terrain
à montréal on pense souvent que médecins
du monde et ses grands organismes ne
travaillent qu'à l'international mais
non ils sont ici aussi tout à feu dont
vous vous retrouvez avec des gens comme
ça justement qui n'ont rien dans les
mains pour prouver qu'ils sont et qu'ils
ne peuvent pas avoir accès est ce que
lorsqu'ils ont des problèmes de santé
liés au vih à l'hépatite c vous les
aidez ce fait ils peuvent consulter peu
venez voir le médecin d'une infirmière à
la clinique mobile camionnette qui
déclasse dans la ville de certains
points
et puis il peut venir y a pas besoin de
carte qui ont ils ont accès ils ont très
peu très peu mais certains ont peut
l'indiquer les notes par exemple
mais louis long on a vacciné on a donné
des vaccins pour la grippe
dernièrement changer des pansements
faire des soins faisable dans une
camionnette
mais sinon ben plus de la moitié ou près
de la moitié des personnes vues par la
clinique mobile sont d'origine
autochtone
plus de la moitié ou presque la moitié
ce que la moitié ce qui est énorme
ouais alors d'après votre étude là vous
en êtes arrivé à plusieurs conclusions
et non énoncé nous quelques-unes de vos
conclusions
d'abord il faut pas besoin de la
situation à metz ça c'est réservé aux
données à ces gens là un repère qu'ils
les lâchent rapport c'est pas un serment
des gens qui vont les prendre en charge
mais des gens chez qui peuvent retourner
sans carte avec leur carte avec leur
misère avec leur histoire et où est ce
qu'ils vont pouvoir retrouver une assise
pour pouvoir aller ailleurs faut les
aider aussi à se dessiner un avenir une
présence à montréal si c'est par choix
c'est bien mais il faudrait peut-être
plus qu'un survivant meilleure situation
qu'en survie on souhaite que ce que ça
se développe
on veut aussi et on veut tous les moyens
que soigner l'hépatite c vienne port
viennent pas d'un problème quand on doit
se nourrir donc il faut se nourrir et
faut être là j'ai avant de prioriser de
le souhait parce que les gens disent
heure où je revenais je revenir puis
viennent pas parce qu'ils ont d'autres
choses avions d'autres chats à fouetter
puis le show il y déjà maigres
donc ils vont ils vont chercher leur
survie avant de avant de venir se
soigner
absolument et donc on doit le besoin
plus étonnant launch le midi et d'envoi
refuge donc que sarah que sa rencontre
objectif là ils sont en tournée dans un
refuge on est dans une situation de
survie après ça belleu c'est là qu'il
faut organiser mais il ya personne n'y
ont pas de newport
y a pas de bus roulait pas des arrêts
des ambassades mais ça me prendrait une
porte ouverte sur la bulle qui
s'apprêtent à le faire
on est des gens qui interviennent les
gens qui vont dans les cliniques mobiles
ou des gens qui sont des et travailleurs
de l'ue qui les aide mais c'est toujours
en situation de survie vous ça ne
dépasse pas cette situation
moi j'ai une question ça serais tu la
responsabilité des communautés
accompagné en sachant qu'il ya une
partie de sa communauté de ses membres
de leur communauté qui sont en deux ans
d'ère d'accompagner ces gens là dessus
au dessus mais ça serait quelque chose
de deux clauses imsa lités olic mans oui
mais quand on parle là comme sondés
santé-sécurité centif sert sociaux des
premières nations du québec et du
labrador ils sont débordés parce qu'ils
ont à faire dans l'école louis et
l'argent vient des communautés pour
soigner dans les cas d'arrêtés on écrit
avec le phénomène de réserve
on n'a pas de réserve à montréal c'est
des gens qui sont lâchés de la réserve
ou qui viennent de l'ouest qui viennent
d'ailleurs il vient de pondre serment du
québec quand on l'a dit beaucoup dit
nous et donc viennent d'une vie est
encore plus loin la vision du rire à
montréal pour une raison bien sûr oui
c'est sûr chez nous et nous amener à
montréal
on n'en connaît pas beaucoup non
exactement on veut faire une petite
pause changer de sujet un sujet qui
n'est pas évident non plus parce que là
on paie on parle de perte de langues et
des langues autochtones qui sont en voie
d'extinction
charles c'est presque le cas de la
langue wendat il a peu ou pas de
locuteurs de la langue wendat exactement
mais il ya des gens qui veulent la faire
vivre et la revitaliser cette exactement
b ce dimanche le 2 décembre à 14h au
complexe sportif de luanda qui aura lieu
une conférence sur la globalisation de
la langue wendat ceara quoi si oui qui
va donner cette conférence là elle
étudié en sciences du langage qui a
permis de devenir linguiste en langue
wendat l'événement s'appelle tony waeghe
wendat le réveil de la langue wendat à
vous nous parler un peu des enjeux que
la langue wendat peut rencontrer par
rapport aux autres langues aussi comment
qu'elle est valorisée ou citer la langue
pour un peuple c'est son identité une
forme d'identité aussi donc quand on te
perds sa langue par une grosse partie de
son identité donc c'est difficile aussi
pour une communauté d'évoluer dans ce
donc wendat qui décide de se prendre en
main et de 2,2 vraiment de vraiment misé
sur l'art après la réappropriation de
leur langue de pouvoir au moins faire
des lexiques et des choses comme ça et à
la coi à la cua si oui elle est là
abandonné 7 ans et un atelier d'entrevue
là qui vous permettent de faire revivre
la langue avec les gens qui vont pouvoir
aller la visiter
parce que là c'est ce n'est pas et
courbes de wendat absolument pas il n'y
a pas de cours de 8 à 2 watts pour le
moment non non ça va quoi la fin des
ateliers sur la langue elle peut donner
des ateliers pour
pour les adultes comme les jeunes de
tous les niveaux qui explique à voyez
expliqué soit la prononciation commence
comme un conte les cris 6 6 2 oh c'est
juste parce que la prononciation est
plus longue donc il va vraiment avoir un
lexique puis une méthode à suivre qui
vaut qu'ils vont être présentés à ce
moment là pour pouvoir bien déchiffrer
bien le pouvoir le prononcé donc voilà à
quoi c'est une jeune femme et elle est
toute jeune qu'est-ce qui lui a donné l
envie de se réapproprier sa langue comme
ça et que je crois que ben je peux pas
parler pour réel mais pour savoir de
vouloir moi je ne parle pas la langue
personnellement donc c'est de vouloir
s'approprier sa langue je pensais
pouvoir comprendre des aspects ta
culture qui qui peuvent pas être
expliqués en français qu'un convoi dans
la forêt on à la voilà justement
et puis quand on voit dans la forêt il
ya des choses qui s'explique seulement
dans la langue donc pourquoi confesse
dans le seul fait on le fait dans cette
façon là donc il ya des choses qui
s'explique plus ou moins bien dans une
autre langue donc ils sont vus là
vraiment c'est de ces d'intéresser les
gens à leur culture à travers la langue
c'est d'aller piquer la curiosité
d'aller favre je pense qu'on fait le
night une langue c'est d'essayer de
dirkou et ben on dit quoi on vient
d'haddad à moi je connais un bon on
vient de de s'imprégner de cette
structure là donc on s'intéresse à son
la faire vivre la partager moi je
connais un mot au rwanda death et on le
partage donc cesser ce qui ce qu'ils
font je pense que c'est ce que les
langues
je peux pas dire morte parce qu'elle
existe la langue et les lacets jusqu'à
plus de locuteurs en tant que tel mais
je pense qu' il faut leur donner des
petits façon d'exister au rien faire
elle même est ce qu'elle parle alors où
est ce qu'elle la mettrie je pense
qu'elles maîtrisent une bonne partie de
la langue je ne sais pas si elle si elle
le parle couramment
il n'y a pas de lecteur dans quelques
jours
elle doit ça il doit savoir on peut voir
sur le site du cdf m2 wendat kaki ya eu
un super site avec un l'excès on trouve
un dictionnaire c'est justement c'est
elle qui a participé à l'élaboration de
ce site là avec sa communauté
donc on gagne à peu près 600 voix 600
mots de vocabulaire donc quand même dû
quand même un bon lexique le il ya assez
pour faire une conversation j'imagine
mais bon il ya ces cct aussi trouvé par
les textes qui ont été trouvés par apa
davin donc avec les missionnaires et
tout seul et on soude suis tout ça donc
on peut voir aussi la prononciation et
tout cela donc alors des ateliers comme
celui là elle ordonnait au marché de
noël de wendat qui est exact mais elles
en donnent régulièrement là pas
seulement dans cette occasion c'est
quand même ponctuelle il y organise des
événements dans la communauté qui vous
est offert elle est consultante aussi
donc s'il est invité à venir donner un
atelier à quelque part belle à de
l'espoir
je crois que oui elle a beaucoup
d'espoir et se fait neuf ans qu'il fait
ça donc je pense qu'elle a un bon bagage
pour pouvoir faire face à un salon wii
vous gilbert et sylvain ce que vous avez
de l'espoir que on va entendre votre
voix là à travers cette étude là c'est
pour dire à tous ceux qui doivent agir
pour aider les autochtones ici en
situation de précarité
donc votre voix pour les faire entendre
que le besoin il est nécessaire il est
nécessaire maintenant là c'est pas
demain demain c'est la journée
internationale du sida mais c'est
maintenant que les ressources doivent
être implantés que l'aide doit être
apportée c'est important déclin tf1 que
ce soit une catastrophe
oui avec montréal se révèle un autre
épicentre dangereux pour pour l'automne
et le vih parce que la population
autochtone de montréal grandit toujours
et ça veut dire qu'on s'attend pas à
voir le nombre d'itinérants de personnes
en situation difficile
chute et oui non au nom de l'assaut
contre mais on encore
on est chanceux par avoir une
catastrophe déjà on a juste une
situation inquiétante mais qui pourrait
qui peut se détériorer à l'épaule les
populations bougeant toujours le
mouvement de ce fait que ces sept cycles
sont fragiles ils peuvent facilement
grandir simplement parce que les
populations vont changer ou pas ce qu'on
voit est incommodé les populations sont
leurs demandes des détenus sur l'île de
montréal soudainement là on vient de
nous envoyer ces gens là c'est un jouet
mais quand on regarde notre session fait
une autre segmentation où notre lune aux
barrières à l'accès quelconque jeu le
l'accès aux allait pâtir ou traitement
de l'hépatite c ça demande aussi d'avoir
le lire les les assurances maladie ces
choses venise assurance médicaments
l'assurance-maladie quaden qui va avec
l'ont il faut qu'on trouve moyen d aider
à faire le pont et c'est pas un
programme spécifique pour réussi une
façon de d'aménager de rentrer dans les
six dans le système puis de faciliter
les connexions seront les démineurs au
niveau de la loi que nous avons eu nous
demandent d'agir en nature c'est césar
sylvain oui on va terminer avec ça
médecins du monde cherche des
navigateurs autochtone vous vous êtes le
coordonnateur des navigateurs autochtone
alors j'imagine que ça va vous ça va
vous aider dans le travail sur le
terrain c'est quoi des navigateurs
autochtone voilà le navigateur
autochtone sont issus des communautés
qui vont pouvoir accompagner les gens
vers les différents points de services
de santé parce que justement il sole et
les personnes sondées affiliés donc ils
vont servir de lien avec le système de
santé pour les naviguer dans les dédales
du système de santé
et puis
de voir s'ils ont suivi de les croiser
ou de chercher un peu où est ce qu'ils
sont dans la ville
si par miracle y ont un téléphone celui
là de les appeler de faire un suivi avec
eux les accompagner pour un deuxième
rendez vous mais justement de prendre le
de améliorer et faciliter le lien entre
la personne et le système de santé
chose qui est celle aujourd'hui
alors si le système de santé ne va pas
vers eux ces systèmes voilà vous
cherchez de navigateurs il faut faire
quoi pour être navigateur il faut
premièrement appeler ou envoyer un
courriel à mener ce mouvement et la
relaxation d'information premièrement
être tokten donc on aimerait beaucoup
avoir un personnes des premières nations
une personne et nuit il va avoir une
session de formation une période de
formation où on va faire justement les
bases du tss les bases en intervention
situation de crise
le serbe caire et c'est plutôt naître le
système de santé pouvoir se démerder là
dedans puis de pouvoir développer des
liens spéciaux avec certaines personnes
pour accélérer et faciliter le contact
voilà et puis ben c'est les seuls qui
est vraiment les seuls critères de base
leur vouloir aider ces communautés faire
un petit un petit geste pour pour
l'améliorer la situation absolument
l'offre d'emploi elle est ouverte
jusqu'au mois de janvier
oui d'abord et vous comptez combler les
deux postes assez rapidement par la
suite on espère votre lettre ouverte
elle a été publiée chez eux assure
espace autochtone vous espérer qu'elle
soit évidemment publié sur d'autres dans
d'autres quotidiens aussi aux millions
d'euros chaque jour est votre but avec
cette lettre ouverte c'est sensibiliser
les communautés autochtones à la
situation communautés et les personnes
dans les communautés et aussi dire ou à
ceux qui sont dans les dents la place
que aussi que pour les autochtones ça
sert à rien nous dire on ne pas les
budgets en a pas un programme
on n'a pas la chose parce que il n'y
aura jamais assez de docteur de montréal
pour l'instant il a va passer d'un
autochtone pour justifier là bas soit
mais c'est quoi que vous pouvez faire
dans votre boîte pour que cette boîte
lorraine portes ouvertes pour les
autochtones dans ce cas enfin pour que
ce soit plus facile d'accès pour que au
lieu de dire vous avez pas de carte
d'assurance maladie
on est un petit système utilisé temps en
temps mais qui dit ok on va vous la
retrouvez votre carnation
on va trouver votre numéro et vous serez
plus et un numéro ici vous allez être
une personne
accueil voilà j'espère que le volant les
yeux la communauté absolument
merci beaucoup gilbert emont professeur
à l'université concordia merci d'être
venu sur notre plateau sylvain beaudry
dont je rappelle coordonnateur
navigateur autochtones chez médecins du
monde merci beaucoup bonne chance avec
votre recherche d'emploi
jean baucou merci beaucoup à la semaine
prochaine mathis merci infiniment à la
semaine prochaine aussi et puis la
semaine prochaine je vous le disais
c'est kwanten condos qui sera là sur
notre plateau avec joël rébillard de
musique nomade on va parler de la
plateforme en musique que contiennent
une ligue à meaux une alors ne ratez pas
ce rendez vous là donc vendredi prochain
merci à bientôt
[Musique]